in the 1970s thousands of chicken heads
rained from the sky in europe making
foxes and other wildlife confused and
very happy
why
they were filled with a vaccine to fight
the deadliest virus known to humanity
since the 1930s a rabies epidemic had
been sweeping across wildlife
populations in europe and humans wanted
to finally get rid of the virus once and
for all
rabies is named after lissa the ancient
greek spirit of mad rage and has been
haunting us for at least 4 000 years
it can turn animals into angry beasts
and humans into zombies that fear water
but what makes lissa fascinating is not
just how bizarre and deadly its
infection is but also how incredibly
good it is at avoiding our defenses
[Music]
viruses exist on the edge between life
and death hardly more than a few genetic
instructions that need living cells to
multiply
the lissavirus is simple even for a
virus
it has only five genes that is the
instructions for five proteins that let
it solve complex problems infect a
mammal avoid its immune system travel to
its brain make more of itself and infect
new hosts
let's see what happens if you get
infected
it all starts with a bite most likely by
a dog carrying millions of viruses in
its saliva pushing them deep into the
tissue
the goal is your nerve cells your
neurons
they are living electrochemical wires
transferring signals throughout your
body and can stretch for up to one and a
half meters with their cellular
machinery on one end and a terminal on
the other
the terminal is where cells talk to each
other by passing chemicals that convey
information lesser probably binds to the
receptors that are crucial for this
process and slips inside the
unsuspecting nerve cells
inside the virus has to solve a big
problem it needs to get to the cellular
machinery to take over the cell and make
more viruses and because neurons are
pretty long this can be far away
there is a solution at hand though
cells have microtubules spanning their
insides that give them structural
integrity but they also provide a track
system for a specialized delivery system
dyn motors are actual motors that use
energy and deliver packages
they're made from 50 different proteins
10 times more than the virus and look
like a little pair of shoes
lissa uses one of its five proteins to
hijack this amazing system and order it
to head for the nucleus
what's the immune system doing to
prevent all of that
well unfortunately not much
usually when a virus attacks your
civilian cells are crucial in activating
your immune response
they notice that they've been infected
and released hundreds of thousands of a
special family of proteins the
interferons that well interfere with
viruses we'll have to simplify a lot but
in a nutshell interferons alert your
immune system to make antivirus weapons
but they do much more they tell civilian
cells to turn down their protein
factories for a while which means the
viruses can't replicate efficiently
anymore
and interferons tell your cells to
become super transparent which is
important because how can your immune
cells notice that your civilian cells
are infected when viruses hide inside
them
your body solves this by creating
display windows into their insides
called mhc class 1 molecules
cells constantly produce stuff to stay
alive and to showcase to your immune
cells what's going on inside them they
take random samples of their products
and put them into these tiny display
windows to give a peek inside
interferons tell your cells to make way
more display windows and become super
transparent
if a cell is infected and forced to make
virus parts your immune cells will see
these parts in a window and order the
infected cell to kill itself and all the
viruses trapped within
this is one of the most powerful methods
of wiping out a viral infection
unfortunately lesser blocks your neurons
from making interferons and stays
basically invisible to your immune
system in contrast to many other viruses
when it replicates it doesn't kill its
host which would also trigger alarm
systems
instead it stealthy jumps from neuron to
neuron very slowly making its way to
your brain
this phase can take weeks to months and
very rarely even years and depends on a
bunch of things like if the bite was in
your face or foot or how many viruses
got into your muscles
lissa is a patient monster until it
reaches its goal your brain stand
finally the immune system catches on
that something isn't right and reacts
it dispatches some of your most powerful
antivirus cells killer t cells to seek
and kill infected cells and wipe out the
enemy
in other viral infections this would be
a turning point but in rabies the t
cells are rushing towards their doom
simple lissa with its five proteins
plays a you know reverse card using the
immune system's ingenuity against itself
your central nervous system is a very
fragile part of your body and so the
immune system has to be very careful
a few haywire immune cells in your brain
is a quick way to die
so they aren't free to enter your
nervous system they have to be invited
in and can be kicked out
to protect themselves your nerve cells
can order t-cells to self-destruct if
they think they're
overreacting and lissa figured out a way
to make infected neurons express this
order
so as your powerful defense cells arrive
they are ordered to commit suicide
now the virus infiltrates the stem
once this stage is reached you are going
to die
how little kills
one of the most irritating things about
the lysovirus is that we still don't
know exactly how and why an infected
person dies our usual idea of viruses
causing damage is by multiplying rapidly
killing their host cells once they've
made enough copies triggering a massive
immune reaction that also does a lot of
damage
but this doesn't seem to be what happens
here brain tissue of rabies patients
shows minimal sometimes non-existent
damage
instead of murdering everything in sight
it's currently thought that this wreaks
havoc by messing up the neuron
communication inside your brain so much
so that it can't function anymore
this leads to symptoms like confusion
aggression and paralysis
now the virus begins to leave still
traveling through neurons it migrates
away from the brain and heads for the
salivary glands
this is remarkable because after
traveling in one direction the virus
reverses its course after decades of
study we don't know how this works
melissa ends up saturating your saliva
ready for the irate mammal to bite
another and repeat the cycle
while this seems like the beginning of a
zombie outbreak luckily there are no
known cases of a human biting another
and spreading rabies this way
now the end is near
you are rapidly developing encephalitis
a swelling of the brain with many
unpleasant neurological symptoms from
lethargy to paralysis
slowly at first and then suddenly organ
after organ fails as you slip into a
coma there is no known effective therapy
barely anyone has ever survived lissa
once symptoms begin to show it is by far
the deadliest virus we know
except there is actually something that
could save you a vaccine
rabies was one of the first diseases
humans developed a vaccine for
as vaccines do it prepares your immune
system for a future attack so it has the
right weapons ready in high numbers
the horrific tricks of simple litter
don't work once you are vaccinated and
the vaccine is special for another
reason because lister is so slow in the
first few weeks it can be given to you
after you've been exposed
so you can still be vaccinated after
you've been bitten by an animal which is
super important if you've had contact
with a sick wild animal say a bat
because you often don't even notice a
bite from tiny teeth
rabies is a monster
one that has followed our species around
for thousands of years that our
ancestors were terrified of and rightly
so
it still kills around 60 000 people each
year almost half of them children
we are far from eradicating this monster
it lurks in the shadows in forests and
animals of all kinds ready to return in
greater numbers if we ever forget how to
keep it at bay or if we continue the
trend of being suspicious of vaccines
let's hope that one day humanity slays
this monster so it can become like most
monsters part of our imagination
there are much deeper levels of
knowledge to explore about rabies than
the glimpse we just showed you but
digging into sources and scientific
information on your own can be
intimidating so we've partnered with our
friends from brilliant to create an
interactive course with hands-on lessons
to guide you through some of the
concepts we showed in this video
brilliant is an interactive learning
tool with over 60 courses in maths
science and computer science they make
science accessible with a hands-on
approach think of it as a one-on-one
tutoring version of a kotzkuzhak video
your experiment with how fast the virus
can reach your brain based on its
protein makeup or run simulations on
rapist genetic evolution to explore how
mutations create the deadly virus we
know today you can do things like
manipulate energy to see how black holes
are formed or control the expansion of
space itself to determine the ultimate
fate of the universe to get some
behind-the-scenes science coaching on
space and biology and many more topics
go to brilliant.org nutshell and sign up
for free and there's an extra perk for
kutzonk
the first 200 people to use the link get
20
off their annual membership which
unlocks all of brilliant courses in
maths science and computer science we'd
love to go down a rabbit hole with our
research brilliant will take you by the
hand to come along on the right
[Music]
me
[Music]
you